did you know Hillary Clinton has a new
book out the failed presidential
candidate is embarking on a massive
promotional campaign for her memoir of
the 2016 election where she's again
blaming everything from James Comey to
the Russians to sexism for her loss and
she's again condemning the so-called
deplorable z-- for president Trump's
triumph he was willing to play let's not
forget Islamophobic politics homophobic
politics sexist politics I mean he hit
every single area of resentment and
grievance that people were feeling and
his racism which was endemic to his
campaign wasn't subtle at all she's also
refusing to accept blame for being on
the wrong end of the biggest political
upset in decades when it comes to the
self-inflicted wounds when you look at
the list of them and you go through them
in the book mm-hmm did you make enough
mistakes yourself to lose the election
without any of the other things you
talked about well I will say no Matt I
don't think that will surprise you all
right so Kimberly remember when
President Obama or then-senator said
Hillary you're likeable enough mm-hmm
apparently he was wrong about that too
oh don't make me feel sorry for her five
seconds they're gonna do but here's
what's interesting she's actually doing
a better job of promoting this book and
being far more fascinating and
interesting than she ever was as a
presidential candidate certainly got
blessed because she was the first female
to to run like she did the whole deal I
give her credit and props for that but
now it's all of a sudden Hillary
actually is somebody that everyone's
talking about the contents of the book
because she is being pretty forthright
and pretty transparent talking about
everything and all the reasons why and
how the whole like you know kill list of
everybody that's wronged or poorly
advised her everyone you know who's
responsible in Hannity had last night
the thirty two new reader reasons why
she lost right the via the election but
you know obviously she's mad and there's
like broke broke camp with
Matt Lauer I don't know there's all
those love lost there that's true they
had such a good thing going one I kind
of I feel like she's not in touch with
reality Hillary Clinton and I feel bad
for her but that's probably why she lost
the election why do you think she's not
in touch with reality I mean because
she's blaming everything under the Sun
for her loss except her own performance
well I think her performance is part of
it I really still think that there
wasn't a great campaign she wasn't a
great candidate but that's not to say
that that's the reason she lost I mean
she's in the book and in the interviews
that she's been doing she's been quite
specific about the impact of commis
decision just days before the election
to restart this investigation is
specific its impact on Women Voters and
Philadelphia suburbs and you know she's
not making up the numbers those are
analytics done by other people it's show
she took a steep drop
once Comey came back and introduced the
idea that you know this investigation
this email stuff is never going to stop
so he did put the emails on a private
server so the power of this
interestingly from your perspective
jesse is that it was us at Fox and Fox
Business who focused so heavily on the
emails but guess what you know it was it
wasn't the swing voters and it wasn't
the Democrats who went over to trump I
mean so I don't know that you can blame
it but she feels like there was
unnecessary attention to what otherwise
would have been a small topic yes
anyway Dana yes how would you like to
respond to one Williams made me think of
something about a an anecdote that I
remember that Donna Brazile told about
the Philadelphia suburb suburban women
in the year 2000 so its neck and neck
gore and bush and gore just can't pull
ahead of President Bush in that area and
they think well that's could be a real
problem for us because Pennsylvania was
one of the possible states that
President Bush didn't end up winning but
when they do the focus-group a week
before the election they basically they
ask a basic question who would you
rather go to prom with george w bush or
al gore and to a person they're like
well george w bush cuz i'd have a lot
more fun and it would be great and she
said that that's when she thought that
they would probably lose and it was that
likeability factor so it does really get
back to that and Mark Steyn on Tucker
Carlson show just had I thought
it was a really good point that the
media did cover the email story partly
because they were forced into it but the
New York Times did break the story and
it's also she she's so predictable and
president Trump was not and that human
nature is to go and look for something
that is new and interesting and so
President Trump benefited from that the
other thing she doesn't do in this book
at all is admit that just a small bit of
effort in Wisconsin in Michigan and
what's the other one there's a
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania that that
could have actually turned things around
for but certainly in Michigan Wisconsin
yeah don't you think I mean that was a
pivotal she was she was asked like what
should you have gone to Wisconsin
because oh but we campaign there she
sent Tim Kaine and her husband there
that so she's not the same yeah Tim
Kaine definitely doesn't have arrived
the vote Greg Hill in the doghouse again
when you see Hillary out there and she
is doing a great job
promoting this book it kind of reminds
everybody I believe why they didn't want
her as president because she's not a
leader no one has made more off losing
than Weight Watchers I mean she's like
she beats Weight Watchers the Washington
Generals you name it the Cubs
she's like the back of an old stamp
she's bitter and she can't get the job
done oh no I know I can't be nice to see
that yeah I can't I can't be nice to her
after hearing what she just did you know
the things that she just said is
essentially she just did the deplorable
zahl over again doubled injustice an
entire group of people as racist
homophobic Islamophobic she slogan
should go from I'm with her
- I'm withered because she's passed her
sale date you know in her book tour is
essentially saying this is what you get
more of me it's like this is your
punishment because you didn't vote for
me I'm going to your town maybe she will
go to Wisconsin if she could sell books
there and out so go to Wisconsin she's
like a reverse ice cream truck you know
what nobody's running out to chase her
they're all climbing behind the windows
and peering out though about the other
that the blinders is she gone just I
just find it very depressing like that's
a thing she's like listen I got
something else in cyan another reason
why yeah it's just I don't know it's
like I kind of was like hey maybe this
is kind of interesting but after
listening to that weird
stilted manufactured in front of a back
weird background of her unloading this
litany of like race cards Islamophobic
card homophobic gotta go you know who
needs it who needs it this is this is
not good for the country this is why she
lost shut up and go away Trump and says
Trump played to his back which he said
was kind of lame she said no other
Republican he was the leading problem
because other Republicans would not play
the race card wouldn't go out her you
know the Mexicans and homophobic and
Islamophobic and they're saying oh no
that didn't happen she shouldn't mention
she I don't really can't come up with
one example of homophobia the guy was
for gay marriage before Obama was the
you know who she is
she is exactly like Michael Scott of the
office remember Michael Scott oblivious
to the flaws that are on display for
everybody when he walks to the office he
thinks he's got it made and everybody's
going oh my God he's so resistible
she is so resistible but she's got her
entire life is a blind spot she cannot
see the what the men she chose in her
life from Bill Clinton to to keeping
Weiner around before through her friend
I mean these are these are massive
mistakes that she refused to acknowledge
it's just when you see it like this you
go like again go away I guess that makes
tim kaine dwight shrute Don unless he's
like backup harmonica so I mean plays
harmonica pretty nice I want to get
Kimberly's reaction because Hillary is
at it again on CNN saying this about the
inauguration I write in the book about
how really strange it was to sit there
and to listen to the kind of speech that
was so divisive the rhetoric was hot I
call it a cry from the white nationalist
gut instead of taking the moment to say
you know what I want to reach out and be
the president for everybody you know he
didn't win the popular vote he squeaked
through in the electoral college he had
a chance to really begin to fill the
role and that didn't happen that day so
Kimberly she's not trying to unite the
country obviously she's still
try and divide by saying that Trump's a
white nationalist and he's playing on
white nationalist fears that's not
usually what someone does when they lose
a presidential election they kind of
achieve an elder statesman status she's
not achieving that well it's pretty
unprecedented you haven't seen anybody
else behave in this fashion have you
never know you have not you didn't see
41 when he lost you know the book and
behave in this way and so it really just
tells a lot like this I mean he's little
climate freak she's the first this is
the first but it's true but it's very
bad if anybody's deplorable it's her
behavior and conduct I really think so I
don't think that it's setting a good
example she should be dignified and say
okay it did not work out I tried very
hard and I don't know if she thinks
she's ingratiating herself to people by
being divisive like this and actually
just really perpetuating a false
narrative by trying to say that the
president is a white nationalist I mean
we were all there for that you know we
were there for his inaugural address and
you know I I didn't hear it like that
and I just think it's too much of a far
stretch she loses credibility by trying
to tell us what to think and change
actually the narrative you know what
hurts me is I I think a lot of people
did hear that came to me and so it's not
just mrs. Clinton and you talk about her
being blind I wonder if you know you
could also say it in Reverse that gosh
you know somehow Donald Trump said some
pretty incendiary things and some people
might say well that's the great
disrupter and we wanted change I think
lots of people want to change but to
just turn away and pretend oh you know
raise distaste you know playing on
resentments and grievances wasn't part
of it to me that's a blindness to now I
think what he was missing make America
great again he was talking about all of
America and she chose to chop it up into
pieces he only means white America
he doesn't mean you this is a guy that
worked in New York for years in Queens
he worked with every kind of person he
doesn't care about who you sleep with or
what you look like
only if you can help him but the bonus
here in his pageant but you know what
does she wanted to be at first and she
is at first the first presidential
candidate to lose an election and write
a wine all a blame all you know for
didn't do it Dukakis into a dolt into it
and nobody no-nobody
she is a historical first
congratulations I love the wine off it's
at the wine all or blame all all right
coming